when it comes to getting started on
YouTube it can be frustrating sometimes
when you don't really know if your
channel is working right maybe you are
someone like me who's multi-passionate
you have a lot of things you want to
talk about but you haven't really
cracked the code on how to actually grow
your YouTube channel well today is one
of our favorite things to do here on the
think media podcast and that is live
Channel reviews if you're watching us on
the replay I suggest you grab a pen and
paper because you could be taking notes
on some of the things that myself and my
special guests today uh are going to be
sharing with different content creators
at all different levels we'll have
people who have just started their
YouTube channels and will probably be
able to do some reviews on some people
who have been at this game for a little
while so grab your pen and paper and we
can jump into today's Live reviews I'm
excited to tell you that this stream is
a partnership with one of our favorite
companies vid IQ and I am joined by none
other than my special guest Viper from
vid thank you he is the man about tech
he went from a corporate nine to five to
becoming a full-time content creator and
executive producer at vid IQ he achieved
this by believing in himself and
embracing the grind that comes with
being a content creator I know we can
all relate to that if you're watching
this stream you know that for sure
um there are no shortcuts it's all about
doing the work and I'm joined by my
special guest and vid IQ representative
Viper Viper how you doing today hey yeah
what's going on Heather how you doing we
are live wow all right it it is my
favorite to be able to bring energy to
the stream and we will always have
energy when Viper is here Viper I
remember I love that you said you went
from that nine to five into becoming a
vid IQ executive producer it's so
incredible I remember years ago when
Clubhouse started do you remember
Clubhouse are you still on clubhouse are
you doing that thing on a daily basis so
yes I remember it's still going
I love it and Viper was such a staple in
the video Community when Clubhouse
started and it's so awesome to see
um you hear we've got some fans that are
already here I wouldn't say fans I'd say
community members and um we're on a
competing stream happening right now
right Viper
yeah and funny because but IQ goes live
every Wednesday so badaku's live over
here right now too so fun well hey
here's how Channel reviews work um on
this channel you can drop your channel
if you'd like a review like Don just
dropped his here and our think media
team is in the comments they're grabbing
those channels for us so that Viper and
I can look at them we're gonna pull them
up these are blind Channel reviews
meaning we've not seen these channels
before we're going to give critiques
based on our own personal experience and
working with hundreds if probably not
thousands of content creators on a
monthly basis to help them be able to
grow their YouTube channel we're going
to give insights into those Channel
reviews you only need to drop it one
time and this is being streamed in a few
different places so if you're part of
our video ranking Academy Community
welcome to this live stream you can drop
your channel review or if you're
watching this live over on YouTube you
can do the same inside of the comments
so our team is everywhere right now
grabbing several different channels on a
first come first serve basis for us to
do that and we're also going to be going
to be doing some q a so if you have a
question you want to ask us go ahead and
put a couple question marks before and
after like Robert did here and that just
helps us to know when you're asking for
your channel review maybe something
specific that you'd want us to cover in
that review so I'm going to pull up the
first one here and see where it would
takes us
um looks like we're going to start with
Jesse's Channel I'm going to pull up
Jesse's channel here and thank you
Victoria from the think media team
grabbing that I think this is going to
be a good one for us to start reviewing
um let's go and just get started Viper
uh right away do you know what this
channel is about
uh they would have planted one business
at a time so with some type of Planet uh
saving channel from what I'm getting
from uh
because I thought plants because I saw
plants and then I was like oh saving the
planet one business at a time
um okay so saving okay uh Planet 1.5
maybe that's a brand name that must be
like a brand name that goes with it here
we go
okay growing a green business got it
okay I know more what this is about
all right first off what is your take on
the thumbnails Viper
ah I think like somebody's thumbnails
like the what is ESG and the
sustainability reporting thumbnail I
feel like they're kind of missing some
content like I'm I I mean I can
appreciate the solid colors that she's
usually put on thumbnail but
that kind of doesn't really do the video
just as far as knowing what what I'm
going to expect when I click on the
video so it kind of leads the element of
mystery up in the air which sometimes is
good but sometimes
you're not really doing enough in my
opinion to let the viewer know what is
going to happen what is the video about
so I think I feel like she got a little
a little bit more some of the thumbnails
yeah
um I definitely see that maybe in the
last just couple weeks she's maybe tried
some different things with going into
these thumbnails and it looks like
consistently posting content starting
about three weeks ago so if we really
look at this you know it took a year off
of posting content and then jumped right
back into it three weeks ago so maybe uh
doing some YouTube studying I can tell
even with the titles of these videos
like this one here got 80 views this is
a good title sustainability reporting
with the gri standards three simple
steps
um so I think that's that's good when
you think about like getting the exact
videos your target audience is looking
for uh is a is a wise thing to do and
looks like we started or before videos
were about two one minute two minutes
long and we're actually getting some
quality videos out here now with five
six four five videos that are happening
here looking at this about page though I
mean looking pretty good when you look
at what this could be join our workshops
in real life so we're getting some call
to actions hire a team to develop your
sustainable challenging sustainability
projects
um so that's pretty good to see that
they are actually giving some call to
actions in there
you know I'm glad that people are using
their about page because I don't know
how many you all are aware but the
YouTube algorithm actually take keyword
from your about page uh when they're
trying to figure out who to put your
videos in front of so don't sleep on the
about page make sure you're using it to
give a good idea of what people can
expect from your channel and what you
want to do but also understand that the
algorithm is looking at your about page
as well
yeah jumping into some shorts um I don't
like that they don't show us how long
these have been anymore did you notice
that change on YouTube like before you
could see when it was posted what do you
think about that that kind of annoying
to be honest with you it feels annoying
because I'm like well were these posted
all in one day was this you know what
does this look like uh looks like
they're batching she's batching though
so congrats on batching your content
these four look like they're created
same shirt same place same Vibe so
um so that's good and I mean getting
better at these right here look at this
last one 400
um
400 views already Coca-Cola is polluting
the planet you know why that's a trend
writing on that Trend super smart
looking at the environment
they have some amazing benefits that
businesses are getting from really
investing time money and resources into
being an ESG first organization you know
what I'm thinking too if I look at this
one nope okay so I was wondering if
maybe she was creating content from her
content that would be a really smart
idea um to see what she's doing there
anything else you want to talk about on
this one here Viper
uh no I think uh I think uh it seems
like she like she just started what
three weeks ago or something like that
so I mean for the amount of content that
she has out there for being in the game
for three weeks that's she's already off
to a fast start so keep up the good work
and keep up the consistency because
that's really what's important you got
to be consistent with the upload so keep
up the good work I love that and looks
like there she just started using the
community tab also
um mix this up get some photos in here
maybe some gifts in here use it like a
social media feed and that can help
um and that can help you uh with your
channels here I got some questions that
just came in
um let's see we've got this one here
this one says should I type my link more
than once for you guys to see it is that
okay you only need to type it one time
School field Studios and our team will
be able to get that that helps us to be
able to grab those Channel reviews so no
need to type that out more than one time
so just keep it one time is all you need
um
uh still working on the hook of my video
any tips wouldn't uh won't say no to a
channel review okay so we're gonna do
just Channel reviews today so if you
have a question uh you can ask that
question or if you'd like your channel
to be reviewed you can also uh you can
also click on uh you can also drop your
channel here so I've got one that's
about a thousand subscribers we're gonna
get to this one here and
let's go all right so first off couple
things I see with this one this is Tech
Edge Tech Edge
Tech related Channel they already got
their handle so it looks like they
already jumped right into that handle
game so they can get their uh their
handle going here
um Viper do you have your handle already
yes
yeah super smart super smart uh what are
you seeing right off the bat
all right so we go back up to the banner
you put your channel name in the banner
um but you're not really giving me an
idea what to expect from the channel by
looking at the banner it's not to feel
like you're missing an opportunity there
so I would think I would consider
putting some type of value proposition
in the banner just so I know what to
affect uh at a quick glance when I get
to this channel uh as far as the content
goes seems like you're doing a lot of a
lot of content about Elon Musk uh which
is the hot thing so I guess that's a
good thing to jump on right now with all
the crazy thing going on over on Twitter
or Elon Musk so uh good job jumping on
that that trending and uh taking
advantage of that
yeah and you can see that even with the
representation of the views here 396
views when their last videos are 17 11.
this one here again Elon Musk so really
uh really smart to jump on those
different Trends let's go here to videos
we can see how long they've been
creating content actually let's go back
here Channel's been up since October
2019.
and let's go to this about page and see
if we can figure out a little bit more
uh this is a place for Tech news
innovation in the world tech gadgets and
gear we cover everything from Elon Musk
to Tesla to new technologies and
incredible inventions that um actually
exist that actually exists you won't
believe what you find here all right so
um they're really making their Channel
based on Elon Musk because they put that
inside of their title
yeah yeah
uh how do you think these thumbnails are
looking and what what do you have to say
about maybe some of the titles that are
happening
um let's see
I mean the thumbnails I feel like I like
the thumbnails that were more recent
better than these are are we looking at
right now
um but as far as titles go I like the
fact that they're using shorter titles
because what you all need to realize and
say if you use longer titles when people
are searching for your content YouTube
truncate the longer title so you want to
try to keep your title as short as
possible
um but obviously if you have to put in
more information in there you can do
that but remember
even if you think you need a longer
title you could put some of that in the
thumbnail if you want to add like
additional contact to the title but it
might be too long for the actual title
with soap think about putting a couple
of words to text in the thumbnail I
wouldn't put no more than three words or
text in the thumbnail but you can also
use the thumbnail to supplement your
title as well so you got to be able to
use everything that we are offered here
if I click on the most popular it's
really
popular for them I mean this is a
breakout video three months ago
um this new hydrogen breakthrough shocks
American scientists
um I would wonder if they've already
made a part two to that or a second
video that could go along with that
because 46 000 views is definitely a
breakout on their channel here
um when I look at those those uh
different videos that are really
skyrocketing
all righty um Community tab uh how do
you how do you like to use the community
tab Viper
so the community tap is a little
different because I know some people use
their Community tabs at content dump
they just put like the latest video that
they uploaded on there and that's not
really the best way to use the community
tab in my opinion it should be more for
what you're doing behind the scenes or
maybe you have a video that coming down
the line maybe you want to talk about
that or you can use it as a way to give
feedback from your viewer your audience
uh you can do polls in there I think
they now have image posts that you can
do in there as well so you can Poll for
different ideas of what the audience
wants to see and just general engagement
with your audience so that's what the
community tablet really there for and
that's how I feel like we should be
using it as to have that extra
engagement with the audience that you
might not understand be able to get on a
video
yeah so how would you rate the way that
Tech Edge is using their Community tab
so far
um not enough
uh you should be using it as often as
possible hey use it daily if you have
the bandwidth but definitely using more
than once every three weeks that's just
that that you're not and I'm guilty this
as well I don't even mind nearly enough
so uh I would definitely suggest you all
use your community tab at least a few
times a week if at the minimum
yes I think that's good and Tech Edge I
would say
um uh I let's see I don't see shorts on
here with you so I see that you're not
quite making shorts yet as a content
creator
um with this type of content especially
when you've got 46 000 views on this uh
video I'd recommend that you maybe break
that up into a short or could you make
the same video a lot shorter could you
maybe take out the biggest point and
turn it into a piece of short form
content and that can maybe increase some
of the views that you're seeing on your
channel but good job at Tech Edge
reaching that 1 000 subscribers on your
way to the 250
000 minutes of watch time and 250 000
yes I said that right sometimes I get
messed up but when I because it's 4 000
hours
and then you make that into minutes and
then yeah it just becomes the whole
thing so
um well Viper we're excited because
you're joining us from vid IQ and vidiq
is definitely one of our most favorite
companies that we get to partnered with
that we use and we actually use them for
several years a couple things one I'd
love to know what you love about working
with bit IQ as a content creator and
then two uh how people could jump right
into
um to using vid IQ as a platform
yeah well one of the cool things for me
about working with vid IQ I should say
forfeit IQ is that it's not a typical
nine-to-five job I pretty much set my
own schedule as long as I get all my
stuff I need to get done I can set my
own schedule which means that I'm doing
work for vid IQ but that also means that
I have time to do my own content on
YouTube because obviously I'm a content
creator of how I got the the after I got
noticed and things like that so it
allowed me that that flexibility to do
what I want to do while still getting
the bit IQ stuff done
as far as the actual tool itself because
bit IQ is a creative tools we have some
awesome tools over there um one of my
favorite uh something that we call Daily
ideas and basically how you're using
that if you're coming up with like a
let's say you have like Rider Buck or
content creator block you don't know
what to make a video about we have an AI
that will literally generate video ideas
based off of the things that are
happening with the videos that you've
done in the past and other creators in
your Niche and the content that they're
doing and have done in the past so it
basically just Aggregates a bunch of
different ideas and it presents it to
you and then you could pick which ones
you want to save and hold on to or
you could take those ideas and change
them up a little bit to make them
uniquely your own and
oddly enough or I should say not only
but actually right now we are having a
Black Friday sale for standing up to use
our booth here which is like our middle
tier uh you can get six month of booth
for a half off by using the promo code
cyber week at checkout so if you are not
you live at IQ I would definitely
recommend you go try it out especially
since we have a free tier um even if you
don't want to pay for anything right now
you can still try to free tier to see if
it's something that you can use to help
you grow on YouTube so check it out
so so cool I use the Boost plan I love
it so much let me know in the comments
if you're watching live right now either
on Facebook over on YouTube are you a
vid IQ user and tell other people one of
your favorite features
um inside of the vid IQ Eco system it's
one of my favorite things uh that um
that I use as a content creator because
it gives you all the ideas guys you
don't have to overthink it that IQ makes
it so easy with all their Ai and how
they're able to do that all right we're
going to jump into a few more um Channel
reviews
um but we've got a question coming in
from Christianity explained I've been
doing book reviews on my channel how do
I go about doing a batch record for
books so I don't burn myself out Viper
do you batch record and what advice
would you have for this content creator
uh I don't batch record but I have batch
recorded in the past uh
basically you just have to uh set aside
a block of time that you need to sit
down and record your content
why not throwing out to one uh it's
either if you like break it apart so
me I'm a crazy man because when you
leave when I put out a video I will
shoot edit and upload a video on the
same day
um that might not be uh workable for all
of you but if you're talking about batch
recording video set aside a day that you
just want to shoot the a-roll or
whatever just shoot the video record the
video you don't edit it or not like that
just record it and then the next day you
can go back and edit the videos or doing
something like that or maybe instead
it's not a day to create the thumbnail
for the video so and basically just all
about uh doing multiple pieces of
content in one sitting uh depending on
how it fits into your life schedule so
if you're busy and you know that
um you're not gonna upload content like
next week or the week after uh batch
recording so you don't have that void in
your content schedule can be clutch yeah
it's really really important I love
batching
um because I like to get uh in the frame
of mind of recording and I think that
it's understanding that not every video
no two videos have to be the same so I
always say well what if we did it this
way because I think that allows you to
know that like not all of your videos
have to be 10 minutes long not all your
videos have to be a video review what if
one of your videos was your top five uh
book review books that you've already
reviewed and you actually just Stitch
that together and that's a video in
itself so always be thinking of uh of uh
what if we did it this way to allow for
you to have a little more freedom when
it comes to your recording of your
videos and not burning out burnouts the
real thing Viper especially as a content
creator because we are always constantly
having to make content
um before we get into this what are uh
what are some of the things you're
seeing or or for you what are some of
the tips you have to not burn out as
you're constantly creating content
I think the biggest advice I can offer
you all is to not compare yourself to
bigger creators when I'm doing these
thumbnail audits on Twitter every
Thursday they're they're telling me that
they're doing different things because
they see their their bigger favorite
Creator doing it and that's not always
going to be a path that will work for
you because you have to understand that
don't bigger Creator they've been doing
it for a lot longer they've established
their brand they're known they have an
audience already so they can do things
differently from what a smaller newer
Creator can do so you can't always do
everything that the bigger creators do
so my advice would be to avoid burnout
avoid comparing yourself or trying to do
or model yourself after your bigger
Creator friends or a bigger Creator
Faith or whatever uh develop a support
system around you for creators that are
uh around your similar uh part in your
journey like newer creators or creators
that have been doing it for a few months
whatever have that support system in
place so you can like help each other
grow and get through it because that is
a lot more realistic than trying to
compare yourself and trying to do things
after a bigger Creator mm-hmm yes Amen
to that that is so so true and stay in
your own lane how you might create might
be totally different than how someone
else needs to create so um it's also
just remembering to say in your own lane
all right let's get into a couple more
Channel reviews we're gonna do some
rapid fire Channel reviews here
um Diary of Diary can we say that one
more time Diary of an artist already at
6.5 uh thousand reviews almost hitting
that uh watch time so we can get to
monetization here and right off the bat
um I'm seeing a really great header what
are some things you love about this
header Viper
I like the fact that they have their art
utensils and and just pieces of Art and
the thumbnail I mean thumbnail any
Banner because let me know that there's
an art channel right the bat we're
dealing with an artist and probably
content about art and I love that when I
look at a channel better I get it I
immediately get a sense of what I'm
gonna get on the channel that's how I
feel like the banner should be you when
I look at your banner I should get an
immediate sense of what you're trying to
do with your channel and this Creator
hits the home run with it
and now we've got this um vid IQ uh
plug-in right here this vph why is this
important Viper uh when you see
something like this happening on a video
vph for those of you are going off aware
is view per hour and it can be important
because if you are because not only if
you have the vi I mean let me start over
if you have this video if you have been
IQ uh installed on your browser the VPS
won't just show up on your channel it'll
show up on other channels like Heather
has here and if you see another Channel
with a very high vph then that's the
potentially trending topic that you
could jump on at the Creator and make
content similar to that all around that
so it's always it's always good to pay
attention to the vph that you see on
somebody else's Channel especially if
they're in your Niche because if they
have again if they have a high vph video
in your Niche that means that that topic
is resonating with a lot of people and
that's something that you could
potentially make a video about
definitely so this channel to me is uh
showing kind of a lifestyle Vlog uh
style Channel
um what is your advice to vloggers Viper
when it comes to creating content and
are are you are you for or against
blogging as a channel
Okay so
it's like we get to the lot on bit IQ no
here's the thing you all and somebody
might be a troop that you might not want
to hear but I'm here to give it to you
anyway
uh you can Vlog as a new Creator and
this is basically for newer Creator
because I'm guessing most of you all are
newer creators are just starting your
journey but as a newer Creator you can
Vlog but nobody knows you so you just
can't blog for the sake of vlogging you
have to figure out a way for that Vlog
to provide value to a potential viewer
why should they watch your Vlog so
here's the thing instead of titling your
Vlog such and such Vlog day one or
whatever or such a Dutch Vlog today did
something happen in that Vlog
um did something exciting happen or did
you learn how to do something that maybe
somebody watched the Vlog they can learn
after you are you teaching are you going
to teach us how to do something in that
vlog so think about titling your Vlog uh
take well I should say think about
taking the highlight of the Vlog and
using that as the title instead of using
Vlogs such and such as your title
because you have to think
anytime you make a video and upload it
on YouTube think to yourself why should
someone click or even your even you why
would I watch this that is the number
one question that you have to be able to
answer as a Creator when you're
uploading content to YouTube why would I
watch this and that go further why would
other people why would stranger watch
your video if you can answer that
confidently then you're good to go but
if you have trouble answering that
question you need to rework your title
or your thumbnail to give a more to
think reason for a stranger to click on
your video
I I could have answered better myself
and even when I look at what her most
popular videos are here's a couple
things that I see one you're definitely
still creating them in a vlog style
um content these are a year ago two
years ago two years ago a year ago so
um a couple things that I noticed one
like answering your canvas questions
um uh this is great 29 000 views you
could do this once a quarter you could
do the same video Once a quarter
answering canvas questions because I
mean we do a channel review on this
channel every two weeks and we will get
new channels new questions same
questions answering a different way new
gas like there's so many ways that you
could do that but you're you're hitting
a nerve right here with answering your
canvas questions
um sketches versus roles how I store
huge paintings
um you're answering questions but you're
doing it in a vlog style so I'm seeing a
lot of your best performing content how
I ship a package this is great this is
exactly what you're just saying Viper
right like what is the main thing that
happened and how does it relate to the
audience and how does it serve the
audience well this is a prime example of
that um for a video
exactly uh art Stewart uh Art Studio
Tour
um it's finally here amazing and by the
way you have beautiful art like you are
an incredible artist and I love that
you're sharing it more and more with
doing these Vlogs but if I'm seeing like
even what these old
um
videos look like versus newer ones uh
this to me feels very vloggy right these
are Vlog style and sometimes some of
them are hard to read like there's a lot
of words happening uh in these um
thumbnails that are harder to read like
and that this one is about Mother's Day
it doesn't matter oh no it's not about
mothers it doesn't matter and that's a
good thing you can't even really read
and that's a good thing unless I have it
scaled up on a 32-inch monitor so you
want to be careful about the words that
you're putting into your thumbnails when
it comes to
um creating different types of content
she also did say she's already monetized
and I do like how she is using her
community tab she's making polls here
which is great uh that's helping people
she's um she's putting different uh
photos she's also then giving calls to
action to her videos
um and this seems like a very active uh
she's getting likes here I would engage
people in more questions you'll get more
comments when you engage people more
questions and um looking really good
yeah she's definitely on the right track
keep up the good work yeah keep up the
good work this is a great one here um I
love this too join our co-creator
community let's just click on it see
where it takes us so you guys can't see
it but I can see it um and it takes us
over to a site uh that you must be 18 or
older to view and I'm not going to click
on that um because I am not going there
today so thank you so much for being a
part of our community thank you so much
for dropping that there let's get into
the next Channel review and actually I'm
excited because a lot of these creators
um looks like they've actually been uh
doing this for a little while which I
love to see even if you're a newer
Creator so the Minnesota Timberwolves
have Mason Lewis during this off season
but they are okay let's go here Anthony
or no that's Anthony who's this let's
see my channel oh it doesn't have a name
okay my channel consists of NBA
basketball breakdowns and Analysis of
players studying stats players and teams
Tendencies creating visuals for you to
enjoy and stay up to date with all
things NBA and even historical MBA
events so uh we are at 2.4 K subscribers
doing pretty good on these uh well this
view 10 days ago
um what do you automatically see right
away Viper
I like the fact that he's using uh
uh pictures of actual players in the
thumbnail because they are instantly
recognizable and they lends a bit of
authenticity to content so I love that
and I love like I love how he's using
the tech thing he's putting the players
in front of the tank and he's giving the
tech that 3d effect so I love these
thumbnail the thumbnails are amazing
yeah I mean I don't know if they have a
design background or maybe he's hiring
someone to do this but these are legit
thumbnails these are these are some good
thumbnails um with big words I love how
you said too like just that 3d effect
that's happening really really really
cool
um all right let's go into so Envy so
how do you feel about these types of
faceless channels Viper
you can absolutely have a Facebook
Channel but what you cannot do and I'm
not saying that the Creator doing it I
have no idea but if you're going to have
a Facebook Channel please please please
use your voice do not use a robot voice
on your Facebook Channel because you
just take away from the the personable
uh uh apparent the the human aspect of
your channel it just it doesn't work and
you're not going to get many people to
stay around if you use a robot voice
um the other thing about Facebook
channels is that you can do it but you
gotta inject your personality into it
because it's hard to be a facing Channel
with no personality that it just does
not work you have to remember that it's
called YouTube for a reason you got to
put the you and YouTube and especially
so when we're talking about a faith and
channel
um
one thing I want to point out too here
that I really really love and I wish
more content creators would do this is I
clicked on a video because I just wanted
to see
um this video right here has uh 4 000
views 10 days ago so it looks like it's
one of your better performing videos and
this is what I love to see right here
comments right you someone commented to
you you replied back to them and this is
how you build community right here folks
you comment back look at this I'm I want
to applaud this creator for being in
their comments within the last 10 days
replying back to everyone that commented
on their content way to go that's such a
huge Community Builder piece of that
all right let's just see I want to go
into here and see what they're doing um
okay good this is what I want to make
sure so we've got a copyright disclaimer
posted in here because they're using
other people's content
um so this is a wise thing to do if you
are using other people's content because
he's got the fair use uh permitted by
copyright statue so what they're doing
is just making sure no copyright
infringement intended All rights belong
to the respective owners
um so just giving themselves just a a
cover basically with creating content
that is as I can see here
um it's CR so he's using actual footage
right so he's breaking up actual footage
um which can get you copyright claimed
because you're using footage that says
it cannot be reused uh but it looks like
they put like titles over this one here
so this right here they're actually
creating new content inside of old
content
um which is how you can do some of these
faceless channel uh pieces here
um this to me is definitely a channel
that should be all about Trends so all
about Trends is a big way to know what
you should be doing and what kind of
content you should be creating so you
should be deep into the reddits into
podcasts into you know um what are the
latest things that people are talking
about and jumping on those trends when
it comes to creating content uh in this
space how do you feel about the titles
uh Viper or comment on that okay
um so we need to talk about the
copyright thing for a minute uh just
because you have that disclaimer in your
description means nothing it literally
means nothing okay
um you have to remember YouTube has a
copyright content ID system so the
algorithm looking for a Content that
does not belong or I should say the
algorithm the computer look for Content
that has been uh uh tagged by its actual
copyright owner so if it catches you
using that content it's going to flag
you anyway regardless if you have an ID
in there or not so what you have to do
with this Creator did and actually have
transformative content and what that
means is that like Helder was alluding
to the big creators having he has
overlaids he has titles and things over
the actual content so he transformed the
content into something different that is
legal what you can't do is just
re-upload click from NBA game with no uh
no edit to the content nothing like that
that will get you copyright claim and if
you do it enough you'll get a copyright
strike and as we all know if you get
three copyright strikes your channel is
done it's out of here so be very careful
but understand that having all that in
your description means nothing
um you have to make sure that the
content itself is transformative you
have to do something with it not just
real not just reuse it and re-upload it
especially if it does not belong to you
that is that is a great explanation
um because that's what I said I'm like
well I mean they've got it here which is
a good thing but at the same time if
you're just re-uploading content that's
not good so my thing too is um if you're
gonna create content that is going to be
faceless you've got to do your homework
you've got to understand stand what the
rules are because we are using the
platform of YouTube to grow your
influence to grow your income so you
should understand what game you're
playing and understand what the rules
are and how you can work around those
work with those rules um to be creating
great content that helps people but is
not
um it's not going to get you shut down
right
exactly all right we've got this uh
content creator here
um
elune Jill TV that's what I'm going with
what are you think in Viper elune Jill
TV sounds about right to me all right
and can you tell right away what this
channel is about
no
um he's a commentary in the banner which
is fine but commentary about what I mean
there's a million things you could be
doing commentary about but that Banner
doesn't tell me what you're commentating
on or about
looks like this is a shorts Creator
um with a few long-form videos
um and this creator also after I clicked
through a couple of them looks like
they're just uh they are taking content
and recreating content and getting views
from that content a lot of views from
that content
um is happening over here uh but it
looks like just taking from TV shows and
and uh
commentary like other people's content
is that what you're seeing
yeah it looks like you are taking
content that does not belong to you and
again I got just explained
um you can get in trouble for doing it
if you're not transforming it you might
be transforming it we haven't we don't
we're not looking at the content so I
don't know but if you are not
transforming the content they will come
for you
yep so looking like it's a shorts
Creator
um and then Dwyane Wade ex-wife speaks
out
um okay so just let's see is there
actual commentating
okay so they're actually he's actually
in the lower third here commentating on
this content which is good but I don't
know if that's actually happening on the
short form content
um
well probably should let me click on
another one I should read the titles
before I click on things hey all right
people
um Dave Chappelle yeah that's what I
would say about this one this one to me
seems like uh he's now jumping into the
game of actually commentating on things
um
which looks like it is starting to work
here Andrew Tate reaction all right I
would not start a video like this I know
we're not doing video reviews but this
is not good I would not start a video
already we are we are uh eight seconds
in and nothing but a title has happened
so far I would definitely switch that up
um but this to me okay so this is a
reaction style Channel what are some
tips you have for reaction style content
when it comes to using popular content
like this
emotion is there is really all about
emotion because if you're reacting to
something I'm expecting you to have some
type of emotion so you need to be able
to relate that emotion either in your
title your thumbnail or both
um otherwise why am I going to watch
your reaction what makes your reaction
different or more viable than the
hundreds of other reaction channels on
the on YouTube so you gotta gotta figure
out how to differentiate that and the
way you do that is by adding that
emotional content to your reaction maybe
using one of the the legendary YouTube
shock place in your thumbnail or some
type of emotion in your face and your
thumbnail that relates to or that gives
us a different a little bit of an idea
uh which way you're leaning or maybe you
uh have some type of emotional statement
at the end of the title or before the
title to let her know that all right wow
he's going in or or she mad like I need
that emotion if you're gonna react to
something I need to know that it makes
you feel some type of way and that's why
you're talking about it yeah I I think
that uh reaction style channels are they
you you actually have to be really
entertaining like you are actually
really I mean and that's that is a hard
thing to do a lot of people are not
entertaining they think they are but
they're not actually entertaining and so
you've got to have that like
entertaining Gene to keep someone from
to watch from the beginning towards the
end
um which is a hard thing to do uh when
it comes to YouTube and I love how you
said that Viper you've got to figure out
what makes you different how can you
stand out from all of the other reaction
channels it has to actually lie on you
as the Creator to make that happen all
right we're going to get to a couple
more channels really quick if you're
just joining us right now hit that like
button um Viper and I Viper is from the
vid IQ family we're doing a
collaboration uh right here and Piper
you guys are live over on vid IQ doing
this type of work all the time what is
what can people expect if they subscribe
over on vid IQ
well if you come to the bit IQ YouTube
channel uh we do two live streams a week
on Tuesday we do content similar today
if we do actual Channel audits like
we're doing now uh today on Wednesday we
do video reviews but we actually click
into your video and we will watch the
first 30 seconds and we'll let you know
what we think about your editing your
your presentation style uh things that
you can improve on things that you're
doing correctly different things like
that so we do Channel audits on Tuesday
actual content audit reviews whatever on
Wednesdays and then throughout the rest
of the week we're just doing different
educational videos uh either telling you
about different ways that you can grow
on YouTube or highlighting a vid IQ tool
or YouTube new so uh if you wanted to
know about everything growing on YouTube
uh vid IQ is the place to be
so so true and actually uh right now
nope okay not live anymore but oh yeah
still live still live over on vid IQ
um when we are done with this stream
here if you're watching live and you
want to get more action like this you
can head over to vid IQ uh where you can
hang out with them uh to be able to get
channel reviews video reviews and all
the fun things
um that are happening over on that
channel I love it I think it's a really
fun uh channel to watch I watch him I
actually watch you guys all the time I
love watching good IQ appreciate it
all right let's get to another channel
here we've got
um cooking with uh Caitlin Viper we know
exactly what this channel is about right
exactly I mean she makes it so easy got
the picture food in a banner uh Eve it
says easy meal for busy lives I mean I I
love it I mean I love when people just
make it easy for me to understand what
I'm getting
it's my favorite and you're right like
four busy lives guess what I'm not doing
this isn't like slow cooking you know
all the things taking all day living on
a farm she's like you have a busy life
let's get this going so
um all right oh jumping in right away
what do you think about these thumbnails
oh you're not okay
no so I would I gave you if you used to
praise with the banner but the thumbnail
we're gonna need a little work the
problem with the thumbnails is that you
are covering up the food and you're a
cooking channel not it's like a cardinal
thing you don't want to cover up the
food the people who are coming to the
channel to see how good the food looks
so if you're covering the food up with
the tank when you are doing yourself a
disturbance and the viewers are gonna be
like I don't know so definitely work on
making it either one making the type uh
or using less Tech making it smaller or
Hell eliminating entirely because you're
don't don't whatever you do do not cover
the food with the tank don't do that
yeah
um I also want to encourage uh you
Caitlin I see that you're definitely you
know you're going at it you're making
this content you're doing great you're
getting videos up looks like one time a
week so great job in that
um your homework for this week is to
study food photography
um I think this is really wise if you're
doing any type of uh before and after
DIY food specifically is to actually
really study food photography because
one thing I can notice is you can maybe
even up the saturation in these photos
just a little bit it'll make them pop a
little bit or get yourself a really good
um Lightroom filter that would be on
here that could uh really I mean there's
really good ones you can purchase on you
just go to like Etsy and you can buy
some really good photography filters
that you can just slap right onto your
photography
um because what I would say is is
especially when it comes to food you
want it to look good like you want it to
look really really good well this crock
pot soup looks good it it's a white bowl
with a white background so I need a
little bit more to make me really
enticed to go and click through that
let's see what some of your popular food
is because maybe uh Caitlyn you've got
some things uh some okay you do so
one of the things I'm seeing that you're
really good at and that your audience
likes is these crock pot recipes they
really like these crock pot recipes
because your last uh your top six you've
got three of those
um happening in here so that's really
really great to see four of them okay
lots of crock pots not that you need to
turn into a crock pot Channel but it's
just knowing what you're getting views
on and knowing how you could go deeper
with that so
um I don't know if you've done a crock
pot review video I don't know if you
compare different crock pots together
um I am a person that has no clue what
I'm looking for when I'm buying
appliances and so I wouldn't know the
difference between crock pots um so I
would these are just some ideas that you
can have because just because you're a
cooking channel
doesn't mean that you can't also be uh
doing review types content around the
the uh different pieces that you're
using to create your content
um I love that she's using a lot of
these like four I saw this a couple
times like four budget friendly things
so it's more than one
um five easy fast easy and fast freezer
meals apple crisps that looks good I'm
kind of hungry now Viper whenever I
review a cooking channel I get kind of
hungry
uh shorts making some shorts over here
as well
um looks like you're getting you're
starting to figure out how to do those
actually making a lot of shorts so
maybe even posting one video in one
short a week looks like
is happening over here yeah I would turn
the saturation I would figure out maybe
the lighting here also like this this
feels pretty dark
a little more light if I'm just
critiquing your actual videos
yep I agree yeah and then uh using that
Community tab two hours ago two days ago
good job bye
nice all right what do you have to
review on this one anything else I left
out on that Viper no I think we nailed
everything with that channel uh she she
talked to a good start uh keep uploading
the content uh keep getting better yeah
really like it really great job all
right I'm gonna let you start off this
one here let's see we've got ladies Farm
a life on the farm well we know exactly
what this is about this is a great
Channel Banner by the way
yeah absolutely uh life on the farm
now this is me kind of nitpicking but
there's a lot that can happen on a farm
so I'm just curious like what exactly is
your content going to cover as it
relates to farm life because Farm life
is a big vague topic like there's a lot
you got you got animals you got like
Farm duties you got Farm uh Farm stables
and equipment and housing and stuff so
what part of it are you focusing on are
you just trying to focus on the big
Niche that in farm life so that's
probably my first critique um you might
want to figure out how to narrow it down
uh into a more uh or more Niche uh
subject area so people can better
identify with the content that you want
to do it looks like you're doing a lot
of Homestead stuff so that might be a
place to start
yeah I um I follow a lot I'm really
really fascinated by the farming
community and kind of the homesteading
community but I follow different people
for different reasons like I follow one
girl because she does all things canning
like she's just amazing at canning I
follow another girl because she does
everything with goats and again they
both do the same things but it's what
are you emphasizing on and that's a
really good point here Viper because if
I look at the content she's currently
creating my trip to Virginia which is
great except I might not be interested
in that that might not be it because I'm
getting a trip to Virginia and I'm
getting homemade wing sauce
feels a little feels a little dis uh
disjointed
um vlogging looks like vlogging's
happening they were doing like a van
life conversion so I think this is one
of the pieces where people fall into
where um it's not an over sharing it
actually just isn't a uh narrowing down
of focus that can happen when you're
creating a con when you're creating
content on YouTube
oh go ahead what were you gonna say
honestly the way to think about this is
think about when you step into somewhere
like a Dunkin Donuts right you're
stepping into a Dunkin Donut because you
want a donut probably I mean you have to
have coffee they have breakfast food
they have uh ice cream as well depending
on which one you want which one you go
to but you're not going in there for all
that you're going in there because you
want a donut so when people come to your
channel they need to be able to
recognize instantly what they're going
to get from your channel now when you
grow an audience then you have the
opportunity to expand your content but
when you're trying to grow first
starting out you got to be more focused
about what you're going to present to
the audience so they can get comfortable
with you and then as you grow that that
although that time to expand will
actually come for you
definitely
um I am not a huge fan of this
um text on the okay I like this one like
Garden Tour I like that better
um and it feels it feels like
we're not I'm not hitting like a
branding side like it feels very uh now
we are we're kind of getting a little
bit better with some of the the uh the
look and feel of it
um but like even in this jalapeno jelly
there is a lot happening in that one
photo one photo's got a lot of things
happening and I don't quite know where
to look I want one jar of jalapeno jelly
just like a jar sitting there so that I
know what it is because we've got tongs
it's in a kitchen I see you so it almost
looks like it's a screenshot rather than
an actually good well done thought
through
um thumbnail also uh the jalapeno jelly
and the jalapeno uh the candle jalapeno
the thumbnails look way too similar
um you might you might mess around and
have your viewers or your subscribers
skip that video because they feel like
they've already seen it if you make them
too similar so be careful with that too
um I think these channels are going to
really really uh this to me is like a
huge branding play a huge personal
branding play so I'm really excited that
you are um look at this new videos out
Sunday Wednesday Friday mornings uh
you're really hustling so um I think
this is great for being able to grow the
excuse me getting able to grow uh the
the
um uh branding of what you're doing uh
but I would just say let's let's focus
maybe just a little bit more on one
piece of the farm rather than the whole
Farm as a whole but good job so far as
you are growing go ahead before we move
on uh what is that branding at the
bottom left of your thumbnail
um I don't know if that's your brand
brand or if that thumbnail but you don't
need that in your thumbnails
um you are waking Faith with that
branding so I would say remove that
I think that was that
that like
several years ago when it came to like
really branding what you were doing
um when subscribers really mattered and
now views really matter right and the
subscribers still matter but views
really matter and keeping people on the
platform and even how YouTube has
changed over the years I feel like that
Personal Touch that goes on there isn't
as necessary anymore as it used to be
um back in the day so well hey Viper
we're coming to the top of the hour I
want to thank you so much for being a
part of what we're doing here at think
media if you've not yet already
uh gone over you can get started with
vid IQ today for one dollar and then you
also said Viper that there is a special
happening um our team's gonna drop that
why don't you tell the people one more
time what that is today uh before we
close this out absolutely so uh we have
a Black Friday special happening so if
you thought of a bit IQ about the
Philippines on Friday uh and you can if
you I can all today if you sign up on
Friday with an IQ you can get our booth
plan six months for 50 off uh you do
that by using the promo code cyber week
at checkout and now we'll get you 50 off
for the first six months of signing up
for our booth plan so our boost in
pretty much almost everything that we
offer you get access to all the tools
and everything and I feel like a lot of
you all can take advantage of that and
it might really help you out have an
attitude like pretty much the full tool
tweet for a reduced price for a half a
year so definitely go over there and
take advantage of that if you are able
definitely it's one of my favorite tools
that we use here at think media it's
been a pleasure to be able to have you
on today Viper
um and be able to do Channel reviews you
can head over to vid IQ they're doing
some things over there every single day
so you can head over there as well to
see Viper and the whole crew
um if you want to get more in depth on
your channel reviews and your video
reviews
um that are happening over on vid IQ
Channel thank you so much for watching
today hit that like button if you liked
this stream and if you want to check out
another video here on our podcast
Channel you can click or tap the screen
right now and if you want to look at
another Channel review you can click or
tap the screen right now and we will
catch it in the next live stream bye fam